hey Christopher Cerf is an author record
and television producer composer
lyricist editor and co-founder and
president of the educational television
production company serious thinking
since its first season in 1970 surface
played a pivotal role in the creation
and production of the Sesame Street
television program and most notably as a
regular contributor of music and lyrics
in the process he has won two Grammy
Awards and three Emmy Awards for
songwriting and music production in 1970
he helped launch the most influential of
recent humor magazines the National
Lampoon the Iraq war eaters third serves
third political anthology his second
collaboration with Miguel sippy
Christopher Cerf Miguel sippy is senior
analyst with public campaign a nonprofit
nonpartisan organization based in
Washington DC working on comprehensive
campaign finance reform in that capacity
he has published articles and op-eds in
the Washington Post Newsday The American
Prospect the hill salon.com intellectual
politics.com and many smaller papers and
magazines he is the co-author of
democracy that works a chapter in the
next agenda blueprint for a new
progressive movement and is currently
writing a book on how money and politics
affects people in their everyday lives
his book spoiling for a fight third
party politics in America was described
in Newsday as quote a commanding survey
of contemporary third parties in a more
politically developed country tsipras
reporting would be the gold standard of
contemporary journalism unquote
prior to joining public campaign in 1997
city was an editor and writer with a
Nation magazine for 13 years writing
widely on domestic and international
politics especially the Middle East his
first love and specialty he is also the
founding member of the independent
politics group which is affiliated with
the political science department of the
City University of New York Graduate
Center and I'm honored to also be a
founding member and I'm also honored
that he's here I've had the opportunity
to work with him for about three years
on events like this please welcome Nick
Elsa Prix
well thanks to Chris and thank you
professor president Caputo and we're
very very grateful to pace and to Simon
& Schuster also who made the Iraq war
reader possible basically Mick and I
have done this once before we've done a
book like this for the last Gulf War and
we had a real sense of deja vu this time
because it seemed that the same kind of
problem existed as we thought and in
what the public was seeing and hearing
as we approach this war that happened
the last time which is basically we had
a tremendous amount of coverage 24-hour
day coverage on major television
networks etc but a lot of that coverage
was very much in the moment and there it
seemed to us there was almost no
discussion of the history of Iraq before
all this happened even the last war
wasn't mentioned that much and also
basically what led to the policies what
led to the US and its relationship with
Iraq or the entire West's relationships
with in the least these things weren't
being discovered and I kind of sound
bite mentality they weren't being
discussed so we felt if we could put
into a book some of that background in a
very readable way from people who are
either experts on the subject or
actually helped make the history
themselves or had very strong and
informed opinions about it we could
perform a real service and also do
something very interesting which
mattered to us because we had to spend
the time and we feel we've done that and
we were able thanks to many of the
people here all who contributed to
really assemble some of the most
wonderful writers and thinkers we know
and knew of from every possible place on
the political spectrum we kind of look
at it as a town meeting in print and the
only problem with doing a town meeting
in print is you eventually have a
deadline and they take your typewriters
and computers away and so you have to
turn the book in and we were sorry when
that happened but thanks to pace college
and Pace University and to others we can
keep that town meeting going with events
like this and so we're really glad we
could be here and I'm going to turn it
over to mica now to tell you how we're
gonna work this today thanks Chris
let me start out by thank you let me
start out by apologizing for those of
you who originally heard about this
event when it was first advertised you
may have heard that William Kristol the
editor of The Weekly Standard was going
to be one of our four panelists and
unfortunately a few days ago he had to
pull out he sends his apologies but his
new book was just translated into French
and he so he's off to to Paris France
which we refer to as Paris freedom to to
to to do a book tour there so but his
loss is our gain because we were very
lucky we were very lucky on such short
notice to be able to get Assad Dean
Ibrahim to join our panel and this is
his first public appearance I understand
correctly since coming to the United
States and needing to have some surgery
and we were very very grateful that he
was able to come we're also very happy
that we have such a diverse panel it is
our best effort to reflect the diversity
of voices on this very difficult set of
issues 9/11 Iraq Empire and democracy
obviously there are no black and whites
in this discussion and we are hoping
here for a chance to have some civil
debate and an inquiry that will include
you the audience as participants in
asking questions towards the latter half
of the program we will invite you to put
questions on index cards and hand them
up and we'll do our best to get to as
many of those questions as possible
we're also going to invite the students
who are here for this week-long program
to have a chance to ask a couple of
questions but first we're gonna hear
from our four panelists we've asked each
of them to speak for a couple of minutes
and then Chris Cerf and I will will
hopefully ask some pointed questions and
they'll have a chance to ask each other
question to give this discussion some
focus since 9/11 Iraq Empire and
democracy just about covers everything
we asked our panelists to focus on two
specific things one is the future of
Iraq in the wake of the war and the
other is the future of America's role in
the world which obviously has taken some
kind of a qualitative leap or at least
some people think it has and so we're
hoping that yes we will inevitably get
into the debates over the last year but
that at least we will have a forward
thrust where we are trying to look ahead
to the future the order of the speaker's
was determined by a picking cards from
the stack no no actually it wasn't the
order of the speakers are Saad Ibrahim
who will be followed by Jonathan Schell
then Kristin Singh and then batting
cleanup Christopher Hitchens so let me
introduce our first speaker sada Dean
Ibrahim is a professor of sociology at
the American University in Cairo and the
founder of 1988 of the even khaldoon
Center which is a research and advocacy
center focused on democratization and
civil society in the summer of 2000 he
and 27 of his colleagues were arrested
as they prepared to monitor the upcoming
parliamentary elections in Egypt all 28
were found guilty by a state security
Court and several were sent to jail dr.
Ibrahim himself was sentenced to a
seven-year term he and his colleagues
fought that fought back in the courts
and their cases provoked worldwide
condemnation on march 18th of this year
I'm happy to say Egypt's highest court
acquitted him in two of his fellow
defendants of all charges the rule
the ruling also sets forth some broad
principles of law and caution the
executive branch of government in Egypt
to refrain from usurping excessive
powers among the points made in the
ruling are the rights of researchers to
investigate and report on social
problems in the country the right of
citizens to freedom of expression and
the right of lawful organisations to
accept funding from non Egyptian sources
it's really quite privileged to have dr.
Ibrahim here with us and I'm looking
forward to what he has to say I give you
dr. Saad Ibrahim thank you very much for
inviting me and forgive me for not being
able to stand up the very broad title of
this panel is very telling I cannot
address every item and the title but I
want to start from where this kind
introduction ended my acquittal from
charges in Egypt's highest court that
very episode tells us all about the
drama that's going on in the Middle East
right now a fight between new forces
that are trying to democratize the
region to establish equitable peace and
old forces authoritarian totalitarian
forces that have ruled for so long and
are determined to continue to roll this
fight therefore was not a personal fight
it really was a fight between these two
set of forces in my region not just in
Egypt but in the entire Middle East
because there are other people in Syria
in Iraq of course energy
in Tunisia and Palestine who have gone
through similar struggle to establish
the rule of law to establish democracy
to work for peace the fact that I was
sentenced to seven years in jail the
fact that they fought back was my
colleagues and finally get an acquittal
tells you exactly is the size of the
battle it is not a hopeless battle it is
a battle that can be fought it is a
battle that can be won and therefore I
want to talk about the future of the
Middle East we have to keep that in mind
there are as many factors as many
elements that can push the region toward
peace and democracy as there are that
can set it back toward war violence
terrorism and aggression my second
remark has to do with Iraq itself a
country that I had the privilege of
living in for a couple of years back in
the 70s a country was great assets the
great people was great tradition great
civilization however it is one of those
countries in the Middle East that has
been bedeviled by one of the worst
dictators in history Saddam Hussein I
was against the war but I was happy
about that I would come for this may not
be a very popular position to take back
home but I took it I said where's the
region less one dictator I am happier
and I'll be happier when all the dick
taters in the Middle East disappear
I another minded like-minded are
fighting for that we have no illusion
about how long it will take
we have no illusions about the kind of
democracy we'll have to not be a West
Minister of democracy it will not be a
congressional democracy it will be
little bit missing it will be difficult
it will be agonizing but it will be far
better than we have had for the last 50
years and on that score an activist does
not look at thee all the negative
factors that work against democracy
I work as those positive factors that
can help a democracy and I am determined
with others to make those factors even
if they represent twenty thirty forty
percent success elements we are
determined to make them a majority we
meet were determined to make them
prevail and to bring about democracy my
third point has to do with a peace in
the region I'm gratified that there is a
summit meeting today in chairmanship in
my country that President Bush has
finally decided to get involved and to
work for peace I hope it will work I
will work with other minded peace
activists in the region to make it work
and it is up to you to help us in this
drive
I think peace and democracy are twin
objectives without which this region
will continue to take the
to the brink of war every seven years I
calculated from 1945 to 19 to 2003 how
many times has this region being a
theater for our what conflict ten times
in less than 50 years ten times starting
with the Marine landing in Lebanon back
in 1958 this is the involvement of the
United States alone and if you want
avoid another war if you wanna avoid
another bin Laden if you want to avoid
another Saddam Hussein then you have to
work for peace and democracy in the
Middle East thank you very much
sad you professor Abraham it's really
inspiring to have you very and to hear
you speak and we have a wonderful second
speaker that we would like to introduce
now Jonathan Schell I'm sure most of you
know is a nation columnist for many
years and author of important books many
that you know the most recent of which
is the unconquerable world
power of violence and the will of the
people
Jonathan was born here in New York and
became no reporting on the Vietnam War
for The New Yorker magazine that's when
I first heard of him and he wrote a book
as you may know called the village of
Ben sook which had an immense impression
on me when I was starting out my career
at Random House Jonathan was the
principal author of the notes and
comment column in The New Yorker for
many years he writes for the nation and
for Harper's and foreign affairs the
Atlantic Monthly you name it he's taught
at Emory he's taught at Princeton and
NYU and Wesleyan and he said Harold
willins peace fellow at the nation
Institute he's currently living in New
York and we're honored to have him here
today Jonathan you want to come up
I have to amend one thing that Chris
said the subtitle of my book is power
non-violence and the will of the people
gives you a clue to what I will now be
saying I want to add that it's an honor
to appear here today with Professor
Ibrahim who is who has lived what he
believes and it's really a great
pleasure and an honor to be here I want
to say also that as it happens I live
six blocks from here
also six blocks from where the World
Trade Center once stood and I guess it's
impossible not to think of that on this
day in fact it's impossible not to think
of it on almost any day I mentioned that
not because I want to claim any special
credential I don't believe in such
credentials I think we all have a right
and even an obligation to talk about
things that we haven't personally
experienced but we did experience adhere
very close up in this community I do
mention it because what I want to go on
to say is that I think that the United
States in its foreign policy has headed
off on a fairly drastically wrong track
and at the heart of the debate now
unfolding on that policy it seems to me
is the question of the role of force
shall we rely chiefly on unilateral
force to achieve our ends or shall we
proceed mainly cooperatively and
peacefully together with our allies and
the rest of the international community
and I think that this question resolves
into two further questions and first one
is is violence the best way to bring
democracy to the world and the second is
violence a suitable instrument for
stopping the weapons of mass destruction
you'll recall that these were the two
chief objectives that were set forth for
the war so let's look at the
or so far and by the way I'm afraid to
say I don't think it's over in light of
these questions and then look at the
deeper question of whether Iraq is going
to be a good model for future operations
as the administration proposes the
United States won militarily in Iraq but
at the same time lost the world both
consequences it seems to me are harmful
to the future of the United States
so first democracy the beastial
dictatorship in iraq has fallen and no
one who has watched the people clawing
with their hands and mass graves to find
some thigh bone or elbow of their
relatives can be anything but glad of
that and yet the fact of the matter is
that the current administration has
never had does not now have and shows no
signs of having in the future a policy
of determining its military
interventions on humanitarian grounds if
it did we'd have a hundred and sixty
thousand troops not in Iraq but in the
Congo where three million people are
estimated to have died as a result of
the conflict there in recent years but
the question remains nevertheless
whether the US will now build democracy
in Iraq and whether it will be able to
do so not every liberation is at the
same time a birth of freedom I have to
see that I see no sign so far of
democracy being born in Iraq
conceptually the problem is the
contradiction between of trying to force
people to be free that was Rob's fears
mistake in the French Revolution of 1789
and it proved a shortcut to horror
because the fact is that force and
freedom are opposites practically the
problem is the one we've seen unfolding
on the ground in Iraq if the United
States stands back and does nothing the
result is Anarchy looted museums no
electric electricity no water gangs
taking over the streets but if the
United States steps in it is the
occupying power a dictatorship
perhaps with the help of some quislings
this rubs local nerves raw and popular
resistance starts and in fact it has
already started and about a soldier a
day has been killed in the last week or
so American soldier the falling statue
of Saddam was not the end of the war I'm
afraid it may have been the beginning of
the war we speak of a transition to
democracy but this puts a screen of
words up to cover what seems to be a far
different reality that is emerging
reality is an increasingly ruthless
occupation on one side you may have
noticed the general McKiernan who's in
charge of the troops in Baghdad was
recently moved to declare that American
forces exercised absolute power in Iraq
and on the other side of that equation
is resistance including armed resistance
movements the amount of democracy on
either side of this equation is so far
zero as far as I can tell the future is
in shadow as always but the tradition I
see is - a classic war of liberation
against the foreign Conqueror and
already the administration has canceled
the homecoming of thousands of American
troops there it's not a new story it's
the story of the 20th century in almost
every case the foreign Conqueror was
driven out now what about weapons of
mass destruction well where are they on
March 17th the president said
intelligence gathered by this and other
governments leaves no doubt that the
Iraq regime continues to possess and
conceal some of the most lethal weapons
ever devised doubt has crept in but in
actuality I don't think that's really
the point whether they find the weapons
of mass destruction or not let's suppose
for a moment that they do come up with
them tomorrow and dismantle them the
Iraq war was never about weapons of mass
destruction only in Iraq
you'll recall that it was about an axis
of evil and beyond that it was about the
problem of non-proliferation in general
and it was meant to teach a lesson
and that lesson was that if you go and
get weapons of mass destruction the
United States is going to come in and do
regime change on you therefore don't get
those weapons
well countries did learn a lesson from
this war but it turned out to be exactly
the opposite of the one that was
intended Iran learned it North Korea
learned it and what they learned is we
see regime change coming we don't care
for it so we will get weapons of mass
destruction and we will prevent it and
by the way that appears to have worked
for North Korea and the United States is
the last country that should be
surprised by such a lesson because in
point of fact for 50 years of the
nuclear age we have ceaselessly taught a
single lesson in all of our actions and
all of our policies and that lesson was
if you want to be safe from nuclear
weapons get nuclear weapons that's the
idea that is at the very heart of the
idea of deterrence which even now even
with the addition of the pre-emptive
policy still remains at the core of
nuclear policy now can we really say
that these precedents are a good model
for the future for future Wars for
dealing with the terrorists of the 20th
century do these results offer a good
model for either democratization or for
non-proliferation on the contrary it
seems to me that we have discredited
democracy and stepped up proliferation
and both cases we have turned out to
have advanced the law of the jungle if
this is success I'd like to know what
failure would look like thank you
Thank You Jonathan I'm sorry I reversed
the title of your book but maybe like
our book you can sell to both sides if
you change the time in any case the next
person I want to introduce is named
Chris you may have noticed that just
about everybody on this panel or
involved in this is named Chris normally
and this is not the last Chris you'll
have another one to hear from after this
but I'm going to introduce now Chris
tensing who has been an immense help to
us on the Iraq war reader since we
started he's the editor of Middle East
report and indeed the director of the
entire organization merit the Middle
East research and information project
which for any of you who've done any
research on this subject at all will
already know this is one of the most
valuable resources that we have it's a
wonderful magazine and it's also a
wonderful presence on the web and has
helped us with this book and with our
last one too
chris has lived in Egypt he's a real
expert on the subject firsthand he's
travelled widely and in the Arab world
he's fluent in Arabic which very very
few Americans are I must say and that
gives him a lot of insights that he
otherwise wouldn't have
he's written in foreign policy in focus
for the Boston Globe and many other
publications and appears regularly on TV
and radio to discuss the Iraq conflict
recently but also the situation in
Palestine and Israel and many other of
Middle Eastern situations of which there
are only too many so Chris please come
up and and give us your thoughts
well thank you Chris for that very kind
introduction and thanks very much for
the opportunity to appear with this very
distinguished panel and thanks not for
drawing attention to my relative youth
and inexperience in introduction I want
to make some comments that underscore
and underline some of the things that
Jonathan Schell was saying if in
slightly more polemical fashion and I'd
like everyone to imagine that William
Kristol was in fact here because many of
these remarks were direct written with
him specifically in mind beginning in
mid-february with a massive military
buildup underway in the Persian Gulf and
heated debates resounding in the halls
of the United Nations the American
Enterprise Institute instituted a series
of black coffee briefings on the coming
war to overthrow Saddam Hussein's regime
in Iraq the denizens of this think tank
the prime nesting place of several
prominent Iraq hawks knew that however
hollow their arguments may have seemed
to the millions of people protesting in
the streets and to the majority of the
members of the Security Council itself
they had won the day where it counted in
the bush White House the Iraq hawks knew
that Bush and his team had already
decided to go to war despite their
occasional protestations to the contrary
if White House spin Meister Ari
Fleischer was still serving half CAF
double decaf with cream and sugar
telling the sleepy Washington press
corps that george w bush was a quote
patient man for whom quote war as a last
resort unquote the iraq hawks knew it
was time to drink their caffeine
straight for iraq watchers including
those of us who opposed the war the
transcripts of these black coffee
briefings briefings offered a few
insights into the thinking of Beltway
insiders who are close to the architects
of this recent war we learned about how
it conquered iraq fit into their vision
of a remade middle-east how the road to
jerusalem led magically magically
through baghdad without
any in West Bank settlements and how
invading US troops would be welcomed
with quote kites and boom boxes by
longsuffering Iraqi civilians
particularly oppressed Shiite minority
who might even take up arms alongside
their liberators the last black coffee
briefing on Iraq took place the EEI on
April 22nd looking back at the news
reports from that week the think tankers
had many interesting puzzles to solve
for their audience where were Saddam's
weapons of mass destruction which the
Hawks that assured us before the war
posed a mortal threat to the United
States and the free world why had these
Shiites not risen up on mas to fight the
hated Baathist regime and why were many
Shiites and their leaders talking about
Imam Ali and quote occupation instead of
Thomas Jefferson and liberation
instead of clouding the coffee with
ruminations on these troubling subjects
Newt Gingrich the speaker at that
particular briefing delivered a jolt of
espresso : Powell was squandering the
hard-won gains of the Iraq war by
visiting Damascus and fostering upon the
hapless Bush a roadmap that led past a
few recently parked mobile homes in the
West Bank
I mentioned the Gingrich briefing for
two reasons first because it shows that
the Iraq Hawks have always had their
eyes on a bigger prize and more
importantly because of the date April
22nd on April 22nd the Iraq Hawks
decided that Iraq was no longer worth
talking about it has become customary to
say that the u.s. won the war and is
losing the peace in Iraq but that gives
the Bush administration far too much
credit there were never any serious
plans to quote win the peace in Iraq
only fantasies of succeeding without
triumph we are now watching occupiers
amateur hour
there were no plans to hold the non
petroleum-based patrimony of the Iraqi
people and trust us troops stood by
while looters destroyed the National
Museum there were no plans to keep the
machinery of government in the economy
running US troops watched as looters
pillaged government news ministries
laboratories factories and other places
of employment leaving Iraqis to this day
without work there were no plans to
quarantine the components of possible
nuclear proliferation US troops did not
stand guard at the facility of two atha
allowing possible components of nuclear
proliferation to be looted even some oil
fields in the South were looted of key
equipment with the result that Iraq
today is pumping slightly more than half
the oil it was during the last days of
Saddam's regime there were no serious
plans to bring Baathist war criminals to
justice u.s. troops loitered in the
vicinity while locals excavated the mass
grave at Hilla with a steam-powered
backhoe thereby rendering much of the
forensic evidence useless for peace or
future prosecutions and a few days ago
on May 18th US forces released a major
suspect in precisely those massacres of
Shiites who had risen up after the 1991
Gulf War a man by the name of Mohammad
Jawad aeneas because they were unaware
of the charges against him the only
serious plan for the post-war indigenous
for the country's post-war indigenous
governance was perhaps the dreamiest of
the Iraq Hawks fantasies and now finally
less than a month into the occupation
the Iraq Hawks are learning what most
independent observers have been saying
all along that Iraq is not a gigantic
sketch on which the formerly omnipresent
murals of Saddam can be erased and
doodles of Ahmed Chalabi with wearing
George Washington's powdered wig put in
their place today Shelby's head flak and
Baghdad announced that the Leadership
Council appointed by Lieutenant General
J garner the now deposed American
destroyer of Iraq will be will ignore
the new council that's going to be
appointed by the new American vestroia
paul bremer so soon Iraq could have not
just one but two unelected and
unrepresentative quote interim
governments both installed by American
Viceroy's the only serious plans to
emerge from the US occupation have
nothing to do with humanitarian
intervention and everything to do with
centralizing the levers of power
governance oil and now it seems guns in
the hands of the occupier those who
lauded the United Nations for refusing
to authorize the war are now faced with
the uncomfortable reality that the UN
has stamped its seal of approval on a
u.s. British occupation of Iraq of
indefinite duration with minimal UN
involvement and no built-in timeline for
the transition to indigenous government
what is to be done well if you're in
Iraq Hawk you want to move on to Iran
but I would say that for the rest of us
if we want to talk seriously about
building democracy in Iraq and not just
hallucinate about that Ahmed Chalabi and
stir democracy then the large disconnect
between the recent consolidation of the
US occupation and the war party's
pre-war rhetoric is only one of many
contradictions for us that we have to
deal with there is a looming
contradiction in Iraq between two
precepts of democracy as we idealize it
one being self-determination and the
other being liberalism by which I mean
such things as respect for civil rights
tolerance of dissent and mechanisms for
the peaceful alternation of power the
questions here are many and the the the
relevant question for us as Americans
perhaps the most relevant one is would
the u.s. countenance a self-determined
Iraq which had a self-determined foreign
policy which denied the Pentagon basing
rights refused to quit OPEC and help the
Saudis keep oil prices at their current
high levels and adopted a position on
the israeli-palestinian conflict that
was closer to Damascus than the one in
the Bush White House well that would fly
in the face of everything the US wanted
to achieve by supposing Saddam and so
one very possible outcome in
rakh when the US occupation does end and
one that we have to be very wary of is
that the Hawks will leave behind in Iraq
a u.s. friendly democracy that has all
the trappings of democratic governance a
bicameral legislature like Constitution
regular elections but has none of the
substance of democracy and is neither
liberal nor reflective of popular wishes
we do not want to see the United States
leave Iraq with a democracy and it looks
like the democracy which convicted dr.
Ibrahim and has finally belatedly
realized
thank you Chris our last speaker is
Christopher Hitchens who also probably
requires no introduction but I am gonna
get the sheet of paper that has
Christopher Hitchens who I consider a
friend from many years of both working
at the Nation magazine and though
neither of us are officially connected
with that place I suspect something of
its soul and value still lurks within
our hearts I hope I can say that maybe
look is good okay lurk Christopher
Hitchens is a columnist for Vanity Fair
and the author most recently of a long
short war the postponed liberation of
Iraq widely published polemicist and
frequent radio and TV commentator the
author of many books including why
Orwell matters letters to young
contrarian the trial of Henry Kissinger
as well as books on Cyprus Kurdistan and
Palestine including babe blaming the
victims which he co-edited with Edward
seed he writes for among others Slate
The Atlantic Monthly the New York Times
Book Review and The Washington Post he
lives with his family in the tobacco
friendly city of Washington DC and and I
just wanted one other personal remark I
want to thank him for having been among
the very first of the authors we Chris
Cerf and I called when we got the
assignment to pull take pulled together
this book and he right away gave
permission to us to include two articles
one which reflects Christopher's
thinking about the first Persian Gulf
War and one of course a more recent one
about why he supports regime change and
we really appreciated that vote of
confidence getting that so early and it
was a big help in bringing other authors
into the book so thank you
Christopher and I give you I give you
the podium
thank you me good thank you Chris I also
want to claim my share of the
distinction of being on the same
platform as Professor Ibrahim
ladies and gentlemen brothers and
sisters comrades in in about 9 months
worth of argument now with a faction or
tendency American politics and life
calling itself a piece or anti-war
movement I've never for a day lost my
sense of the serial which has mounted
throughout this argument and polemic in
which I don't think has yet
question though I thought it might crest
today when I read yet another series of
columns showing with what fury and
annoyance the peace movement discovered
the evident fact that Saddam Hussein's
stocks of deadly weaponry have ceased to
exist or will soon do so the annoyance
of this discovery
I think crowns my sense of the
irresponsibility of this movement shall
I recall to you that only a few months
ago the Savannah is saddam hussein
regime itself claimed to be holding
enormous stockpiles of toxin and
chemical and biological material that it
that it insisted to invade nations that
it had these that it confirmed that it
had them and was not understating the
case that it could not and would not
prove that it had destroyed them they
refused even to save its own life to
come into compliance with resolution one
for for one which was a 15 to nothing
unanimous vote the preamble of which
mentions the manufacture distribution
and proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction and that at least half of
the occasions on which i debated with
the peace movement on podiums up and
down the country i was told that a
reason not to have a confrontation with
the national socialist Baathist regime
in iraq was that it would use weapons of
mass destruction to chronic and deadly
effect on American forces on its
neighbors and on its own population in
other words if this is an irony comrades
it's an irony at many people's expense
but one thing we can say either the
Saddam Hussein regime was disarmed or is
this our
or very soon will be and I say that is a
fantastically good outcome some
combination of internationally exerted
armed force or the believable threat of
the same and sanctions and isolation and
air cover for the insurgent regions of
Iraq principally the the northern sixth
of the country roughly contiguous with
Iraqi Kurdistan and the southern
predominately Shia portion around Basra
and the marshes by the way all of those
no-fly zones were acts of war not
sanctions but by the United Nations but
which did prevent the completion of
ethnic cleansing in Iraq mean that I
think my title is justified in my book
that this is a war that began in 1990
shortly after the fall of the Berlin
Wall
with Saddam's attempt to destroy even
the name of another independent Arab
Muslim State actually not just to invade
an occupied but to remove from the map
of the state of Kuwait and that really
the problem has been in the intervening
12 years not a rush for war not a drive
to war not a drumbeat of war but at
least ten years too much indulgence for
a dictatorship so filthy that it was
impossible and so dangerous and so
unstable and so highly toxic that
coexistence with it was morally and
politically impossible
I think this cracked ought to be
confronted and looked at again and held
up to the light and shaken and looked at
again from every aspect because if the
anti-war movement sometimes calling
itself anti-imperialist movement peace
movement had had its way this would not
have been the outcome indeed if that
political tendency had had its way in
general since 1989 and the collapse of
the Stalinism in yerevan kuwait would
still be the 19th province of Iraq the
ethnic cleansing of Kurdistan would have
gone unpunished Bosnia would now be part
of greater Serbia Kosovo would be
another cleansed howling wilderness and
the Taliban would still be the
government of Afghanistan those would be
the battle honest
if their advice had been listened to
which fortunately it was not well this
some what I call refusal of
responsibility simple decline of a
historical inheritance of responsibility
that became evident to many people know
later that let's say the 11th of
September 2001 prompts me to three
reflections comment on three
interlocking international developments
the first is the self-evident fact that
there is within the Islamic world a
civil war on one side of those who wish
to impose Sharia law on everybody in
other words not to have Muslims state
not to have States for Muslims like say
Pakistan but Muslim states rather a
different conception and to impose this
on non-muslims also which can be seen
from everything from the proposed
stoning to death or mean Allah well in
Nigeria and the extension of Sharia law
to the northern provinces and now to the
central and southern ones as well the
civil war in Nigeria on this point to
Indonesia to the to the attempt to
destroy secular government and civil
society in Algeria the attempt to import
Wahhabi terrorism into Bosnia and Kosovo
and elsewhere struggle really intently
mentioned of course in Indonesia
Malaysia - but where there is islamic
resistance Muslim resistance civil
resistance to this course of action and
where those who hope to win this war for
Sharia and for Taliban ISM hope to do so
and to impress and/or terrified of those
who waver in their own society by
exporting that war to our society as
well thus making the challenge one that
is inescapable and this has involved the
building of a secret army within our own
borders supported by dictatorships
outside them which has every intention
eventually of killing everybody in this
room and their families I believe that
we can hope if we exert all our
intelligence and all our cultural skill
to make real friends among the Muslim
world who don't want this outcome for
themselves any more than we do for
ourselves or indeed as a matter of
elementary solidarity and fraternity for
them so the probe is going to be finding
and making allies and making it clear to
the other side that their victory is
impossible
not morally impossible physically
impossible that they will be destroyed
in the attempt and that we have no
compunction about making that statement
in advance making good on it and
preparing to make it come true the
second tendency to which I'd like to
draw attention and which is what I think
finally drew me to the side of the
sinister cabal in Washington that
believed the Saddam Hussein should go or
at least should not have been
reconfirmed in power by the Bush
administration in 1991 as a minimum is
this I do believe that there is a wind
of change a regime change Tennessee in
the region the reason that probably
needs it most the middle eastern eastern
Mediterranean I will just have time to
instance a few of the cases in point for
me the most important or perhaps the one
that had the greatest effect on me was
the embryonic creation of an independent
semi independent let's say autonomous
Kurdistan in the sixth part of the rock
that one-sixth of the North there was
emancipated from Saddam's control in
1991 in that region regime change has
been demonstrated in practice despite
mr. Chen Chen seems extraordinary
cynicism on this point in the most
mountainous backward tribal poison-gas
ethnically cleansed historically feudal
region of Iraq a real new society has
been created there's more than one party
there's 21 newspapers there's an
enormous diversity of opinion this
freedom of movement and there are four
female high court judges and the the oil
revenues are spent on the development of
the people and the infrastructure and
not on the upkeep of a parasitic
psychopathic military oligarchy next
door in Iran the the all the evidence we
have shows that candidates who are post
or theocracy who want a civil society
will continue to win every election that
is held there they're not yet allowed to
take power but they can demonstrate that
they can win the election so we can see
the diminishing returns of the attempt
to create a boring
backward feel proceed out of one of the
world's most high sophisticated cultures
and we can hope as with all the other
cases I've mentioned by the way that the
many millions of challenging exhales who
require great gifts and qualifications
in their enforced exile
should have the right of return to their
countries and the right to contribute
their lives and their skills to their
own societies and we should count
ourselves on their side and on the side
of their right of return I would
instance also the the very clear
movement among Palestinians for a
leadership chosen by themselves and not
imposed from the outside by a group of
corrupt pers a former pseudo guerrillas
for leadership also that's answerable in
negotiation and cannot simply if if it
doesn't like the talks or the
proceedings walk out and say well we can
always go back to brother Saddam in
Baghdad and reignite our rejectionist
option that option now no longer exists
good thing to political developments
among the Palestinians seem to be to be
uniformly healthy and democratic the
collapse of the Kurdish attempt to
excuse me the Turkish attempt to
partition occupy in our next Northern
Cyprus the recent the enormous
concession made by government that got
itself on the wrong side of this regime
change argument is another another case
in point to another very inspiring one
somebody is signaling me that I'm
trespassing not as I'd hoped on my time
but on yours ladies and gentlemen I
think this is probably as far as I I
will be able to get but I'm hoping I had
a third point to make about the
evolution of American policy towards
client state towards Empire and towards
cultural civil war and I just hope
someone will have the goodness to and
challenge me on it
this mic on yeah okay okay we're gonna
go into a more of a dialogue part of our
proceedings now and Chris Cerf and I are
gonna try and ask a quick question to
each of our panelists as a follow-up and
if they'll take maybe two or three
minutes to answer if any of the other
panelists have a quick rejoinder that
they want to make that's okay but
everyone will get their turn the first
question I want to ask is to Professor
Ibrahim and to cite something from
Christopher Hitchens book he has an
essay in his in his book on imperialism
which appears to argue for a benign
imperialism by the United States that we
should be quote a superpower for
democracy and he writes a condition of
the new imperialism will be the specific
promise that well while troops will come
they will not stay too long
an Associated promise is that the era of
the client state and I think we could
probably include Egypt Egypt's current
government in that though he Christopher
doesn't say so specifically that the
client state is gone and that the aim is
to enable local populations to govern
themselves so my quest refer question
for you professor Ibrahim is do you
think that many Arabs are Muslims in
your country or in the region would
welcome this kind of American
imperialism is this a viable notion no I
don't think my people in the region or
any people anywhere would welcome
empires in any form American or
otherwise they would welcome friends
Mercure democracies to help them develop
into the Morrises but occupation and
empire i think will be a disaster for
the region and for the emperor's
can I ask one question to follow that up
too if the democracy or the improvement
toward democracy that we're all talking
about occurs in Egypt do you see any
chance that an Islamist government what
might win that democracy or create a
situation that is not much better than
what we have now this is a question I'm
often asked and my answer is no they
were not when the Islamists will get
broadly anywhere from 15 to 20% in a
country like Egypt we have tested that
empirically we know it's true they're
just organized and that 20% of the
popular vote can translate probably to
as many as 30 or 40 percent of electoral
council votes this is because they vote
as a bloc they are organized however
having said that I think we have to be
consistent we have to respect the rules
of the game even if they were I am a
secularist will be willing to live was
the outcome a Democrat must be a
Democrat not only a Democrat if the
outcome comes in his fashion or any size
therefore I am one of those who believe
that even the Islamist let's say some
other distresses to choose to play the
Democratic game in the process they seem
to moderate and to evolve into Muslim
Democrats like the Christian Democrats
of Western Europe we have seen that
happening in Turkey we have seen that
happening in Morocco we have seen that
in Bahrain in Jordan and in Yemen and
therefore let us not use this fear
arousal to scare the prospect of
democracy in the region
going in order I'm gonna pose the next
question to Jonathan Schell who who who
who ended his speech with a very strong
remark about if this is success I'd like
to see failure and as you were speaking
I was thinking of the story of the Iraqi
man who to escape being imprisoned by
Saddam hid himself in between the walls
of his family's home for 20 years which
was an eerie reminder of and Frank so
I'm gonna ask you this question aren't
Iraqis better off today than they were
three months ago and if just to take the
analogy to its limit if an invading
Power had the ability in 1942 to enter
Germany with superior force and to
depose Hitler and the Nazis would we be
arguing first over whether that power
had the right to do so
if international law allowed it to do so
if it was just after Germany's coal if
it was giving plum reconstruction
contracts to the cronies of its
president or wouldn't we first be
celebrating that the concentration camps
were shut down
and let me take the questions in reverse
order and in regard to the latter of
course we did our very best to do that
we mounted the war on air land and sea
against Nazi Germany it wasn't possible
actually to go in there and overthrow
that government until a lot else had
been done first and that was great for a
whole variety of reasons but the analogy
between Hitler and Saddam Hussein seems
to me to break down that you know at
four out of five points
Hitler represented perhaps the greatest
military power of his time he was able
to conquer all of Europe Saddam Hussein
was an immensely reduced power what what
does remain the same is well actually
probably Saddam Hussein was a worse
internal dictator than even Hitler a
Hitler killed people mostly outside of
its own country in the conquered
countries and especially the Jewish
population so but I'm afraid to say that
not only has the United States not had a
policy of targeting and overthrowing
governments because they are
dictatorships but I think it has been
wise not to have a power such a policy I
think that there are times when the use
of force is justified I think it's when
it reaches the point of crimes against
humanity but I don't think that this was
the most motivation at all of the United
States if you'll recall when Saddam
Hussein actually was committing crimes
against humanity the United States was
sending him anthrax
so so so it's a little late in the game
for us to get worked up about that we
should have stopped it when it could
have been stopped and there were people
who tried that about our administration
the Reagan administration in that case
covered it up and would do nothing we do
have experience of what brings democracy
in this world after all the last decade
of the last two decades of the 20th
century saw the birth of 20 to 25
democracies in the former Soviet lands
there were five or ten right there
Philippines Greece Spain Portugal etc
etc etc what did it amazingly and it's
hard to believe it even today was
massive nonviolent movements by the
peoples of those countries democracy in
its very nature is a homegrown product
it is not something that can be imposed
from without and if you want to
understand why there's looting and Iraq
rather than the building up of some kind
of democracy the answer is that the will
for the change of that regime the act of
positive will are came from the United
States and you did not have a situation
in Iraq perhaps they was just simply too
brutal I'm not blaming anybody of course
but whereas in Eastern Europe for
example the leadership that brought down
those regime solidarity charter 77 had
the training and were ready and the will
to build democracies and those got you
nothing of that kind
existed in Iraq and so we have the
present sad scene we see I do think that
they are better off honestly you know
there can be actions that are mistaken
from an overall point of view consider
for instance British imperialism back in
the 19th century one of its causes was
ending slavery coming from Africa and
actually they did quite a bit in that
way and yet British imperialism of that
time was overall a disastrous mistake
for Western civilization not to speak of
for the peoples who were colonized and
taken over
this question for Kristin Singh
borrowing again from from Christopher
Hitchens who made this point in Slate I
hope I'm not taking all your questions
away Chris I doubt it
what and and this is a follow-on to
where you ended your remarks about the
the problem of real democracy in Iraq
the question was what if 1/10 of the
energy of the anti-war movement was now
devoted to helping the secular and
democratic forces in Iraq and Kurdistan
to giving assistance to a Free Press to
helping to sponsor political prisoners
and searches for missing providing money
and materials for human rights and
women's groups is any of this happening
is there any sign of a solidarity
movement from within the people who have
opposed the war but who profess real
concern for the chances of democracy and
some kind of real civil society in Iraq
or has everyone taken a hands-off it's
not my problem attitude that's a very
good question and I think that I would
agree with Christopher Hitchens in some
small measure that the anti-war movement
does have some things to answer for and
precisely that regard one of the
characteristics of the anti-war movement
and in fact the movement and the
economic sanctions on Iran existed in
this country and internationally one of
its main weaknesses was precisely that
it did not have much Iraqi participation
and there were a few reasons for that
one was that there was a very vocal
radical left of that movement which had
a hands-off Iraq attitude which was a
total non-starter with most Iraqis
especially Iraqis inside the country who
were experiencing the brutality of
Saddam Hussein's regime on a daily basis
there was another sector of that
movement that primarily formulated a
humanitarian and moral critique of
economic sanctions a very deserved
critique of the sanctions of
in the 1990s but chose to sidestep the
question of the responsibility of the
Iraqi regime for keeping the sanctions
in place the sanctions like the war have
to be laid at the doorstep of not only
the United States and the United Nations
but also Saddam Hussein's regime there
was always a symbiotic relationship
there
there was a small section of the anti
sanctions movement and the anti-war
movement which if I may make a gross
generalization was the right wing of
that movement which based its its ideas
primarily in discourses of human rights
arms control concepts like this and they
were often alienated from the movement
precisely because many people in the
movement did not want to engage the
question of the brutality of Saddam
Hussein's regime and its responsibility
for the succession of Iraq pricey crises
over the 1990s and into the into the
present day sadly I would say that so
far that tendency is continuing in the
occupation era and by that I mean that
this tripartite division of the movement
has basically reproduced itself and
there are some people who say that the
rallying cry of the movement should be
us out of Iraq even though many probably
most leaders Iraqi intellectuals in
exile and in the country think that an
immediate u.s. withdrawal would be
disastrous for the country just simply
in terms of basic security and so there
isn't there isn't this this organic
linkage between the movement and and
Iraqis either in exile or in the country
and that has been a major weakness of
the anti-war movement that is not
however it's tracked from the validity
of the moral critique that the movement
advanced both against the sanctions and
against the war
okay okay the last question is for
Christopher Hitchens and I'm torn
between which question I want to ask him
you write one of the essays that we
included in the Iraq war reader in the
more recent one that the United States
is now at war with the forces of
reaction and nobody's entitled to view
this battle as a spectator so my
question for you is how many innocent
civilians are you willing to kill in
order to win this war for example would
you support a pre-emptive attack on
North Korea possibly using so-called
mini nukes if that was deemed necessary
to get rid of its nuclear program
program even if you knew that the
resultant radioactive fallout would
poison tens of thousands of innocent
people
well pre-emptive is now almost the only
word that unfailingly gives me an
erection preventive preventive use to do
it but it doesn't cut it now it has to
be pre-emptive and prevent I think I
perhaps ought to begin my exchange what
I mean by being award the forces of
reaction I'm not going to avoid your
your prisoner's dilemma of course but
I'll just clarify a bit it struck me as
very remarkable after the 11th of
September the United States instantly
found that it had to quarrel with people
that thought it up till then being its
allies in other words the the national
security state systems of Pakistan and
Saudi Arabia were the ones who had
actually incubated and disseminated the
ideas of the and practices of the
Taliban and al-qaeda so people have been
thought of as friendly regimes suddenly
became very questionable I thought that
was one of the great mr. opportunities
of the left in that moment was to say
well here we really have found out how
lousy our foreign policy alignments are
instead of which they left so surely
there must be a way in which it's all
America's fault and we brought this on
ourselves and a huge opportunity was
missed and mount a critique of the
client state but if you look at if you
look at the extension of this argument
into the confrontation with Saddam
you'll see that the United States was
willing to work to quarrel with Turkey
over Kurdistan has never had a public or
the Turkish military on this question
before to obviously help convince the
Turks that was high time they made
concessions on Cyprus to say to the
Saudis if you don't want us to use the
base that we built for you we weren't
will go to gutter instead guitar is also
a Wahhabi Muslim state Kingdom but it
lets women vote and run for office and
drive and it's abolished censorship and
it's hosted al Jazeera in other words
all across the region even though many
of these Democratic revolutions are
fairly millimetric in the Gulf and
elsewhere potentially they're much
larger I think in Iran you tend to find
these days that for reasons of
self-interest and partly survival and
partly perhaps learning from some of the
critique that some of us have been
leveling against this policy for many
years the United States finds itself
more and more on the right side of
things it's it's by its policies not
roughly what you'd hope the
administration for example took quite a
forward position on the on the arbitrary
imprisonment of Professor Ibrahim
Delaine used to be like this so I think
this is a moment well worth as it were
capturing refining and demanding that
there be more of instead of this endless
negativity abstention ISM and cynicism
now though were the cases that weren't
yield to this what Iraq was one in my
opinion in North Korea is another I
don't believe office reasons that Iran
belongs in the axis the state I think
has to meet the three probably
qualifications one that it violates the
Genocide Convention in respect of its
own population or mount some equivalent
atrocity against them a second respect
of its neighboring countries it violates
the laws of war and the Geneva
Conventions and all laws governing war
crimes and human rights that would also
apply it very heavily to us that I was
say in the third that it's sponsors or
helps international gangsterism which is
a Baghdad has been a safe house for
international gangsters and terrorism
for many years I worked myself
interviewed Abu Nidal in Baghdad some
time ago it wasn't very hard to do you
didn't have to make a secret appointment
he was in the phone book
he had a villa his gang was an arm of
the Baath Party and its foreign policy
and then well we should add of course
the fourth which is that the latent or
blatant at it
due to the acquisition of weapons of
mass destruction now rap met all those
conditions and so does or would North
Korea would like to do the same the
short answer to your questions I would
not forswear any method of warfare in
advance I wouldn't I want them not to
think that there's anything I wouldn't
do and I have to here say it Jonathan
that what you said was really startling
to me if I understood you correctly and
I made an initial remarks you said I
think we're moving in through a question
it's a perfect segue which is go ahead
ask him his question no I can do it
quickly
if I understood Jonathan's right you
know I hope I did not he said that North
Korea was driven to get nasty and
acquire nuclear weapons because George
Bush had been unkind to it and hurt its
feelings this is an absolute surrender
and complete negation of truth well I
don't know will we do we have a
transcript of this can we get one I
understood him to say that North Korea
had been pushed into the nuclear corner
by by the United States policy all the
time the kim jae-joong was struggling to
democratize South Korea making every
kind of opening he could to the north
sending food aid helping to persuade the
United States to build reactors to feed
rather provide power to North Korea's
famished and starved and unbelievably
terrorized people all this time Kim
jong-il was manufacturing production
line Fleur for plutonium weapons and
simply laughing and sneering at any
attempt to save his people from his
unbelievable
cruelty now I am wanting a regime like
that to be in any doubt that it would
cease to exist if it pushed this to a
confrontation not just the government
but the state it ceased to exist no
North Korea would be no more as a state
those other people we hope but we would
not in advance just arm ourselves of any
option I think it's very important that
they understand that I apologize for
interrupting but I thought that this
would be a perfect segue into our the
next section of our discussion which is
we were going to let each of our
panelists sort of have one free question
of another panelist so do you want to
make that your your question to Jonathan
or would you like to reserve that was an
observation okay
another chance the answer it was it was
the German it was the germ of a critique
these regimes are not nasty because
we're mean to them
that's a stupid masochistic viewpoint
would you like the chance to make an
observation and responses yes well in
the first place it was not actually the
plutonium program but the uranium
program which was stepped up when you're
referring to I think because and that's
an important difference
certainly north korea has had a nuclear
program actually since about 1985 and
it's been a sort of stop-and-start
business from that period on in the late
nineteen ninety but it had the plutonium
program depending on the reactors that
were brought over from russia has been
the one that has been the subject of
negotiation meanwhile you're quite right
except that it's plutonium you rate
except that it's uranium that the north
koreans got into that business before
george bush came into power but in these
nuclear business these degrees and each
step in the protests is critically
important let's take india for example
in 1974 they set off what was called a
peaceful nuclear weapon and yet it
wasn't until 1998 that they actually set
off five more tests and declared
themselves to be a nuclear power and in
the nuclear business as a nuclear power
that was a critically important shift
and you can see that by the fact that
pakistan felt it needed to respond by
formally getting it to the for the first
time into the nuclear business so also
with north korea when when President
Bush announced the axis of evil' policy
in effect threatening them with regime
change if they got nuclear weapons they
radically escalated their nuclear
program both verbally and in actual fact
by withdrawing also the plutonium
program from the negotiations and from
the limitations that had been on it up
to that point and that's far more
serious by the way because that can give
them an on go
to create six or seven nuclear weapons
every year so this was a very radical
shift not only technically but also
politically and geopolitically and it
was one that was directly triggered by
the bush threat as they said and it's
and it's simply true and not only that
but as I suggested before this change is
actually one that makes perfect sense in
a kind of cold-blooded way at least
according to the logic of nuclear
strategy as it's been propounded by
simply every nuclear power which is that
as I said before if you want to make
yourself safe in a nuclear-armed world
and if somebody is threatening you with
regime change or blowing you off the
face of the earth you'd better go and
get nuclear weapons and an actual fact
I'm hope you're not applauding because
somebody got nuclear weapons but that's
a disaster so so I think the evidence is
very clear that the Bush administration
did provoke the Koreans into a very
sharp and radical escalation of their
nuclear policy and technology
does one of the panelists want to ask
another panelist a question if not we'll
go we'll turn to our students who I know
my question is for Christopher Hitchens
I'd like to know if if you agree with
the question of Islamist participation
in democratic elections free and fair
democratic elections in the earth
Islamic world you have two Givens you're
a well you're well known antipathy
you're devout secularism which I share
by the way and you're well-known and
antipathy to Islamism in general and
your comments about it today I wonder if
you concur with dr. ibrahim z'
assessment that the best way for
democracy to flower on its of its own
accord in the middle east is for
Islamists to be given the right to
participate in free and fair elections
without government interference
interference and without this bromide
that we hear from the regime's of the
region that they cannot open up because
otherwise Islamists will storm the
palace gates where do you agree with
Donald Rumsfeld when he says that that
if the one eventualities the US will not
countenance is for Iraq to become in
some measure an Islamic state well the
two elements to your question one is the
participation of Islamists in politics
and the other is the attempt by some
Islamic forces to impose the theocracy
which would mean there wouldn't be any
politics if anyone to participate in and
I think that that's a line that for
example is very it's very I haven't been
in Egypt for a number of years but my
impression from egyptians i known from
studies i've registered oh sure but he
was approximately correct the the
islamic theocrats the violent Islamic
Jihad forces isolated themselves partly
by the murder of foreign visitors to
look so and by many other atrocities
there there there appeals of populations
very limited the Islamic Muslim
Brotherhood type parties probably would
get between 20 and 25 percent and in an
election we wouldn't be able to form a
government suppose they did I think it
would probably be a very good thing as
it is in Turkey because it means they
have to take responsibility
I have to subject themselves to another
verb further down the road I think that
that enormous Lea spreads the the base
on which democracy is conducted and I
would add as a secularist that anyone
who tries to run a modern or even semi
modern society out of a the teachings of
the holy book will find that they can't
do it they'll be discredited it doesn't
need to be proved again they can try and
prove it if they like it's taken 25
years in Iran to run itself into the
sand but it would happen and I would be
there jeer and say that I told them so
as I would if people tried to run the
United States by the Ten Commandments or
reinstate school prayer but let them by
all means try and let them profit from
the experience what of what cannot be
tolerated however is that when that
failure comes that it is blamed on a
Jewish conspiracy in America that is
behind all the worse of this failed
state and thus it's legitimate to export
violence to a non Islamic societies if
there's any sign of it taking that
course then I think they should be
reminded of what happened to the Taliban
yes Mary I'd like to ask professor
Ibrahim a question if I may he suggested
and I warmly agree that an imperial
policy of any kind even that the 9:1
will not be helpful in bringing
democracy in the Islamic world I
wondered if he could to tell us what
policy by the of the United States would
be helpful in advancing this end well I
heard one of the comments by the way
this has been can you hear me
by the way I enjoyed this very elegant
debate but somewhere along the line
someone suggested that the peace
movement the anti-war movement here in
the United States could do something
more constructive to help civil society
in our part of the world and this is
really where I would start
I would say given the dynamism and the
enthusiasm of the anti-war forces of the
peace forces that we have seen in so
many ways in great American cities it
reminded me of the sixties when I was
here as a student
well this force this energy should
direct some of its creative power to
helping force of civil society in our
part of the world that is one will clear
the collective mind of Arabs and Muslims
from the fact that you guys hate us you
kept asking why does the world work the
divide is the Muslims hate you they
asked the question definitely there why
do the Americans hate us well having
lived in both societies I don't think
there are absolutely hate Americans or
the Muslims hate Americans
nor do I think there is a visceral hate
among Americans to art by people I think
there is a good deal of things to do on
both sides to establish a war
constructive engagement or constructive
dialogue and in this respect you can
help us a lot
you can civil society in our part of the
world still we surrounded under siege by
authoritarian regime
you can break into that siege you can
reach out to us you can teach us a lot
we can learn a lot from you not as a
government but as a people and I think
that is the key to the American genius
is that people can do things for
themselves they don't wait for
governments to do it and that's what
we're trying to do so that's what I will
start second I will hold Rumsfeld George
W Bush and Paul Wall firsts and
everybody who is viewed by my friends
here in the red states as a new Khan
Jochen conservative by the way everybody
among my friends worried we are gonna
seeing these guys in Washington however
I went ahead and I saw all of them you
know one who wanted to see me I saw him
and I must say I did that despite the
advice of many of my Democratic friends
from the days when I was here as a
student student activist because I
learned something in my years of
activist back home it's not to label
people beforehand engage them see what
they have to say debate with them agree
disagree but engaged and that is what
I'm calling calling for a transatlantic
transmitter a naeun engagement between
our people and you America Europe and so
long as we please know that there are
agreed upon very broad goals we will
leave the details so historical process
wouldn't they have to have blueprints
for everything we do let us just get in
the right direction I think we all agree
that operation refresh
dictatorship is something of the past it
should be removed from everywhere who
can remove it from we agree that peace
and democracy are two sides of the same
thing by the way one reason why the
peace process has had ups and downs as
the Middle East is because of lack of
democracy had we had democratic
governments I think we could have
reached a peace agreement ten years ago
15 years ago but the fact that we don't
have democratic governments has made
every dictator hang on to up to the
arab-israeli conflict as his own his own
dirt for staying in power and therefore
I think peace for democracy is a
prerequisite for peace that is the what
I wrote in The Washington Post some two
or three weeks ago and therefore let us
have alliance between civil society and
both sides of the Atlantic civil society
and both sides of the Mediterranean
Christopher professor Ibrahimi if either
of you want to ask question other as we
will turn it to the students - yeah okay
there's Malone another Chris hello my
name is Shalon downs and I'm a student
from West Virginia University and I
would first like hello is that loud
enough hi my name is Siobhan downs and
I'm a student from West Virginia
University and I would like to thank our
distinguished panel for their insights
in these trying times thank you very
much my question is directed to the
entire panel initially what actions
should be taken in Iraq to engage and to
help build a trusting and politically
involved civil society which many people
believe is the first necessary step to
begin the process of democratization in
Iraq excellent question who wants to try
that first well the problem is that
there are so many things that need to be
done at the same time I mean quite quite
evidently it seems to me anyway
self-evident somebody should be fired in
Washington because
oh sorry okay thanks that it was whoever
was some some beautiful must for
appeared behind me because it's not as
if they didn't know that there would be
a great day of repair and care work to
be done once the military half of the
operation was over its and was perfectly
well understood it seems to me
outrageous that once Baghdad Airport was
out from the traffic again that they
weren't landing a c-130 every hour and
just having time to turn it around
before landing another one as with the
Berlin Airlift full of the needful
supplies and also of the Guardians
needed to ensure their equitable
distribution I think the I hope there's
a high-level Inquirer to find out
exactly how many people need to be
impeached for not doing that and second
it seems to me if you make a promise in
advance to the to the Iraqi people that
the civilian Authority however interim
or provisional it may be will because
after all we know that the preponderance
of power would be in the hand of the
occupier for what we hope is a limited
period of time if you make a promise
that that interim regime is composed of
faces and names that are by for and of
the Iraqi people then it's not a promise
you can go back on its simply it can't
be fooled with so on these two points I
think that the process has been very
very badly begun indeed and I think
risks jeopardizing the whole point of
the regime change strategy in in the
beginning the hope has to be though I
think that look there are four and a
half million Iraqis out of a probable 23
to 24 for a half a million of them
forced to live overseas I haven't met
all of them of course I've met a good
number of them most of them have at
least four phd's and speak about five
languages they're full of extraordinary
skills and talents that that enough
confidence is created I think this is
very important in all these societies
true in Iran as well crucially and in
Lebanon and in Palestine that to bring
the Diaspora home to encourage the right
of return because that in itself would
form an important part of the bridge of
advantage and Mediterranean that pres
Ibrahim just spoke so eloquently about
that would be a physical proof of not a
clash of civilization but a fusion of
skills and civil society activism and
that's where I would suggest we bend our
efforts
I just walk to ask cristen Singh if he
has anything to add or suggested to in
an answer to that question - yes I think
several people in Washington should be
impeached immediately posthaste
it's true as Christopher Hitchens said
that virtually everything that has
happened after the war was widely
predicted by independent experts outside
of government - new Iraq and it was only
the media cheerleaders for the war who
told us that that it would be at Ahmed
Chalabi instr democracy as as I pointed
out the first thing that needs to be
done is that the US has to stop meddling
in what otherwise could be indigenous
process for getting together a
representative arrangement for a future
governance of Iraq unfortunately there
is still there is still a a factional
approach which is prevalent both in
Iraqi politics and in Washington
politics where some elements of the US
government have their favorite factions
within the formerly exiled Iraqi
opposition now in Baghdad who they would
like to promote and this is behind a lot
of the missteps and Keystone Cops
appearance of Jay Garner's brief
fortunately brief tenure as American
destroy and it's behind some of the
continuing confusion with Paul Bremer's
approach to the administration in Iraq
so the first thing that has to happen is
that the US has to at least admit that
the UN can do this better than the
United States and they should stop
meddling in the work of the UN Special
Representative who will shortly be
working in Baghdad to work on these
post-war governance issues
thank you hello my name is Kim deceive
us and I'm a recent graduate of Pace
University my question is for the entire
panel and it kind of deals with
something that no one's touched on yet
so I thought I would throw it out there
for you guys can anyone or would anyone
comment on the use usage of depleted
uranium in both Gulf Wars as it affects
our military and their offspring as well
as the Iraqi civilians and their
offspring and to that extent how does
the DoD or the administration justify
the usage of it and why isn't this more
of an issue in the American media as it
affects us greatly thank you there's a
there's a serious ongoing scientific
controversy about the level of danger
that is posed by depleted uranium which
is the cast-off material from the
nuclear weapon program and is used to
because of its great weight in shells
for piercing tanks and other armored
vehicles all I can say about that is
that when American forces are set in two
zones where that is heavy and where
there's it's been recorded they were
required to wear special suits and so
forth the same for European forces now
that suggests to me that whatever the
state of the scientific evidence and
however that will eventually be resolved
that there's enough reason to fear that
stuff that it's simply unconscionable to
be using it in war on civilian
populations
I would add one one one thing to that
that's very disturbing and that is you
may have noticed that the Bush
administration has just repealed a ban
on making small nuclear weapons the
reason for that ban was to keep keep a
sharp clear threshold between
conventional and nuclear war now
depleted uranium doesn't cross that
threshold in any form of a formal way
nevertheless in a certain sense it
because it is a product of the nuclear
industry and it can only exist where
there is such an industry it's one more
small signal that the United States is
ready to profit from its weapon of mass
destruction program even as it seeks to
ban other countries around the world
from getting into that business and I
think it's an untenable position
I'm in an early book of Jonathan's that
the fate of the earth who makes the
unforgettable very decisive point about
nuclear weaponry that we don't have
another world where we can test this
stuff so we better act prudently and act
as if this was the only globe on which
we could conduct the experiment other
words one of the objections to
totalitarianism to begin with is that it
treats people as if they were subjects
in a great experiment on grand
experiment and that's been extended to
nuclear matters justice just as sinister
and in a storybook of his about Vietnam
he was one of the many people to point
out to readers like myself that there
was something horrific about the war
based on the nature you couldn't cure it
the horrific nature of the Vietnam War
from the weaponry used from the lazy dog
missile for example the fragmentation
bomb from napalm from phosphorus from
certain kinds of tactics and weapons you
could include the ghastly colonial and
racist character of the war now I think
what he said about depleted uranium must
be true in other words we should act as
if it might be as bad as we think it is
until we know better but I think it
deserves to be said that for the first
time in history now the Joint Chiefs of
Staff can report to the President and
say mr. president if you wish to give us
an order to remove the despotic regime
of a country it might be Afghanistan it
might be Serbia it might be Iraq with
without doing really very much damage at
all to its population or its
infrastructure we believe we can obey
that order we can carry that out with
what I'll rather euphemistically called
PGM or precision guided munitions the
way the way in which that was done in
those three cases seems to me to have
absolutely altered the whole nature of
warfare and politics and is an
achievement which needs to be refined
along with the weapons but which
obviously is undergoing a steady process
of refinement far less damage was done
to Iraq this time than in the last
intervention of a Kuwait and far more
discriminating weapons were used so this
I think it means that whole qualitative
change has come over among other things
what we what we mean when we talk about
by Empire
can I I have to contest that last
assertion first of all the the the
question is is how many innocent Iraqi
civilians are too many I think that as
we learn more about what actually
happened during the course of the war
we're going to find that the the low
body count which we think exists is
going to rise we're going to find that
it will continue after the war because
of the use of cluster munitions
artillery foreign cluster munitions
particularly in the south-central areas
of Rock Around Hilla and Malaya and so
on kids are going to be losing limbs and
dying from those munitions for perhaps
some time to come we have not seen the
Pentagon mounted comprehensive effort to
remove those munitions from those areas
when one of mr. Hitchens says bet Noirs
American peace activists in Baghdad
during the war went to CENTCOM
immediately after the war and when the
events in hello were just becoming known
and asked the military officers what
they were going to do about this cluster
nations problem the response was that
they've never heard of this place hello
and they thought it was a suburb of
Baghdad instead of its own town there is
a study that I would direct everyone to
done by the project of Defense
alternatives its online as a non-profit
based in Cambridge Massachusetts and
what they have found is that contrary to
Administration propaganda in relative
terms more civilians innocent people
died in the bombing of Afghanistan than
died in the Kosovo campaign and we may
find that proportionate to the size of
the populations so let's not be too
quick to judge the success of our
precision guided munitions
it's time for one or two more questions
from students and then we'll turn it
over to the audience questions hi my
name is Heath a stern and I'm from
Israel Tel Aviv University and I would
like to focus my question on Israel if
there is a lot of talking going on about
a new window of opportunity in the
Middle East and like specifically in
Israel now peace process going on and I
would like to know how everything that
happened in Iraq and in the region would
influence Israel and I'm not talking
about only the Israeli Palestinians
point of view but I'm talking like in
other countries such as Syria and
Lebanon where their regimes haven't
changed this is part of it and the other
part is I would like to know if do you
think the United States will give an
important part for European countries to
take part in this process going on if
there is one going on thank you well
obviously the one thing about it until
1947-48 there were more Jews living in
Baghdad than there were in Jerusalem and
most of them as a consequence of the
partition of Palestine were flung out so
to speak reciprocally by Arab
nationalists sir regimes in revenge for
the maltreatment of the Palestinians it
seems to be one possibly very good
outcome of the regime change in the
region will be the right of Iraqi Jews
to return to Baghdad if they wish
actually it would be an excellent
example for the region in general and
for the for the culture of
internationalism that one hopes to
in-state there and that by the way that
would remove that right have returned
one of the many excuses that Israel used
to give for not compensating or
admitting to the right of return or
compensation for Palestinian refugees
these are still we can't address this
question while Jewish people are being
thrown out of Iraq and Morocco so you
know as to injustice has held each other
hostage I think it's possible really now
to think beyond that kind of crude
ethnicity and nationalism and say the
well it might well be that many
diasporas will see their own
again and be able to reclaim them if
they wish very good not before time
that's a it's a huge question let me say
that I think that the roadmap initiative
of the so-called quartet of the US
Russia the UN and the European Union
does have some modest promising aspects
to it one of them is that it
international eise's the presumed
solution to the israeli-palestinian
conflict that is a step in the right
direction the United States should not
have a monopoly on israeli-palestinian
diplomacy we have seen that the effects
of that have been quite quite
detrimental to achieving peace the other
positive thing about the roadmap is that
it states explicitly that the it's end
goal is the establishment of a
Palestinian state and if those two
things the internationalization of the
peace process and this timeline that
leads to a Palestinian state are held to
by the actor which has the weight to
push this process forward and that is
the United States then that will be a
good thing however there are deep flaws
in the documents which may make optimism
hard to sustain with regard to the
roadmap and the primary one is one
that's rarely discussed in our media and
that is simply the facts on the ground
particularly in the West Bank and one
facts on the ground which is hardly ever
mentioned is that Israel is in the
process of constructing what it calls a
security fence
what Palestinians call an apartheid wall
which in many places encroaches
considerably in to the territory of the
West Bank that would be part of the
presumptive Palestinian state that is
envisioned by the roadmap the roadmap
does not even mention this attempt by
the right wing of the Israeli political
spectrum to advance its territorial
expansion ISM at the expense of peace so
the United States needs to - first of
all it needs to give up its monopoly on
the peace process one would hope that a
future peace some summits not just the
president of United States would be that
the table but also
other actors to even the playing field a
little bit
and also have to stop obsessing on these
so-called illegal settlement outposts
built since March 2001 and focus on the
rest of the facts on the ground that are
potentially going to make a Palestinian
state not viable in the future if it is
established hi my name is Leland Graham
from Winthrop University and this
question is directed towards mr. shell
you cited as an argument against US
intervention in Iraq today the US
support of Iraq in the 1980s I think
that's a great rhetorical point but I
questioned its logic should past
behavior should past bad behavior really
dictate against curtain current good
behavior because we failed in the past
should we be crippled now or should we
rather learn from our mistakes and act
positively
well that's a great question and
certainly I don't I certainly would not
oppose any real attempt to have learned
from past mistakes and to do a better
job in the present but I honestly have
to say that I don't think that that is
the case here I have certainly seen no
statement whatsoever from the current
administration expressing any regret for
the United States support of Saddam
Hussein in that period they simply want
that to go down the memory hole as far
as I can tell so it would appear then
that it's not a real change of heart
leading to a wiser and better policy but
rather citing something in the past that
is no longer current as a as a
justification that is not sincerely
meant for a policy that we need to
advance for other reasons
I need to apologize by the way to
further questioners because in a few
moments I'm
have to leave the panel to to get to
some other folks who are waiting for me
I want to apologize that's what will be
happening in a few minutes yeah would
you accept a small correction with Luger
John yeah it seems to me maybe maybe
well it seems to me that there is the
writing of William Kristol who can't be
here to save for himself in Lawrence
Kaplan and Paul Wolfowitz and many of
the other proponents the strong
proponents of regime change in
Washington and some of them within the
administration many of them on its
periphery there's a very direct
acceptance of responsibility for past
American crimes and missteps in Iraq and
a very strong critique of the objective
collusion between the Reagan
administration and Saddam Hussein during
the iran-iraq war the manipulation of
the Kurdish question by Henry Kissinger
and the capitulation to Saudi pressure
to keep Saddam Hussein in power
reconfirm human power in 1991 my mine
brushin is that that's the
responsibility that's been fairly well
shouldered I wish that the Jimmy Carter
fans would accept their responsibility
for what he did which is helping start
with insight Saddam against Iran well I
think it's true that that that William
Kristol has done that and some of the
others on the sidelines of the
administration but I haven't seen a
single word in an official capacity from
anyone in the administration and that
seems to me to speak very loudly
but he would find the pole wolf woods
had written that I'm sure and there are
plenty of others on the sidelines of the
Iraq debate said there there are plenty
of others on the sidelines of the Iraq
debate who at the time in the 1980s were
on record saying that the United States
should tilt toward Iraq in the Iranian
state department policy was known at the
time and they have simply switched their
position when the winds was started
blowing the other way so there's plenty
of accusations of hypocrisy to throw
around here okay we're almost out of
time and I know Jonathan are you yes you
are taking other than thank you so much
so that leads us to our second question
the first question involves puppets and
puppet government and working on Sesame
Street when I'm not doing this I'm very
sorry we won't have a chance to ask it
but I would like to ask Christopher a
question from the audience
what about Imperial overstretch is the
question something that Kevin Phillips
wrote about in the Iraq war reader with
the sluggish economy rising unemployment
record deficits a balance of payments
problem and a record high national debt
can America afford the policy that
you're recommending and that also seems
to me the kind of segue into the third
point finish which another member of the
audience would love you to finish so
that's our question well that's very
generous and leaves me knows I'm out of
room I'll try and be as specific as I
can the person who really coins the idea
of a pure overstretch is Professor Paul
Kennedy in the rise and fall of the
great powers which was a considerable
success team in the Academy and beyond a
few years ago I don't know how many
people have read professor had his
recent recantation on this point but
it's worth looking up I'm sure you can
find it on the on the web he revisited
his book and decided that he was
completely wrong in predicting that the
United States would overburden itself
with military expenditure he spent some
time analyzing the enormous unbelievable
overwhelming firepower and reach of just
one single US carrier group I think
through now 15 if there's a scheduled
three more and said that the
extraordinary things this confers the
military superiority and a global reach
under mobile of even by the British Navy
let alone by Rome and it's done on
almost minuscule almost millimetric or a
percentage of the inertia gross national
product and may even have a good
multiplier effect sometimes called
military Keynesianism
on the economy on technology and on
employment it's absolutely extraordinary
it doesn't seem to cost anything at all
it may even pay for itself obviously if
the United States had to if there was a
serious civil war for example between
sherry our time fanatics
people know flow rates Sharia type
fanatics and others in a country say the
size of Indonesia means the task of the
task of arbitrating that would be would
be extraordinary and the United States
couldn't take it all on but in use in
most of these cases there is a regional
balance of power to be sought for
example I wanted to say this - Jonathan
- it wasn't time there's the the idiocy
of North Korea's rash and insane nuclear
policy is that it is almost certain to
force Japan to reconsider its
non-nuclear Constitution the Japanese
are not going to live for very long with
the idea of an armed nuclear-armed North
Korea that's why it's not simply not
true to say that North Korea does this
because Bush hurt its feelings and some
fatuous thing to say China has every
interest in not having a nuclear-armed
Japan those China has and is exerting
tremendous influence on North Korea not
to take this insane course of action we
are not alone in other words of this an
intelligent diplomacy can find friends
just as much as it can isolate allies
and I think that's perfu Chur but it's
good to know that in back of this are
about 15 carrier groups in case anyone
really gets nasty and that they're
manned by volunteers and men and women
of all ethnicities and every known
gender and if I can interject them not
having read Paul Kennedy's analysis I am
surprised to hear you say that this
seems to be something that our country
can afford ad infinitum as it were when
the people in this city are seeing the
the class sizes of the schools that
their kids go to increase and firehouse
is closed and and we're not even we
don't even have enough money to spend on
the new homeland security measures that
that everyone seems to think that we
don't think that money is going to build
dreadnaughts meter that's not how the
vessel dredge sort of go run thinking
how can we squeeze the school lunch
budget and build another cruise missile
let's not have the economy work
oh that's what you think wait and you
and you and let's just see ya and
prescription drugs for seniors I guess
so very high on them and the election
was stolen by I know okay I know I know
I know why night I guess I was there's
nothing to choose between bush and bin
Laden I know I know I know I know how
you feel I'm so through with it I can't
tell you I was asking a series quite
relish that but I I was it a trying to
ask a serious question which was it can
we afford this policy at what cost to
our own society and and I was not asking
you to disagree with the goal as you are
expressing it at least but I'm sorry
that I didn't seem to get a serious
answer oh well I can't leave it like
that and I don't want to look I'd also I
dislike putting myself in the position
of arguing from from authority I think I
will just say that if you if you examine
professor Kennedy's carefully reasoned
evidence that its examine his logic in
climbing down from his position that
inferior of a stretch would beggar the
US economy then you might you might be
more enlightened than by my callousness
and frivolity my wants of compassion
well I'm afraid folks that we are just
about out of time and we've lost half of
our panel unfortunately but I'm going to
ask professor Greg Julian to come up to
close our proceedings we will we will
hang around and there'll be a chance to
keep talking for quite a while so I'm
sorry we can get more questions and we
have a reception outside as well where
there'll be books available by Austin by
Chris tensing's man you can't talk to me
without a receipt from now on that's
exactly right the pro bono bid is over
we any time we talk about 9/11 Iraq
democracy and Empire we 9/11 for many of
us was a light that ignited and
reignited our quest for democracy and I
think what the authors have done during
this discussion has reminded us of
the continuum upon which democracy rests
from the very substantive need to
construct basic democratic forms in Iraq
to the more liberal state policies that
we we think we're capable of engendering
in America to what Jonathan Schell was
really talking about which was called
which I would think would be the
transformative notions of politics where
are we talking about a culture of peace
and the globalization with equity and
some more equitable distribution between
north and south aspirations to be sure
but when we looked at power and when
panel looked at power it used to be
enough to criticize America to be
hygienic well we now when we talk about
empire we've really employed the use of
force and we've relegated the idea of
power is being influenced and using our
authority and using our example
exemplary power as possibilities so when
what I think we have here is a continual
crisis of trying to on one hand be
transformative in our democratic thought
while in a political realm move an inch
closer to being satisfied that force can
replace the Gemini Authority and the
more salutary ways of thinking about
power I think what we are leaving here
with is the clearly a dilemma of 9/11 do
we take this as a new form of non-state
actors operating in our realm and
therefore give us the license to go out
and attack state actors that harbor
terrorists one must have think however
Saudi Arabia and why we're using that as
a pumping station
the other thing is that this will
continue hopefully for the next hour and
a half in a much more intimate setting
the McKellen Institute for Public Policy
and management is holding a reception
for everybody in this audience and we
really want you to come there enjoy our
hospitality of Pace University and
moreover give these authors an
opportunity to continue their wonderful
dialogue and Chris debate your we're
thrilled that you're here thank you for
coming and again thank you for all those
people who participated